[Music]
and something's not right news that's
what I always think it's left everything
my wife says funny just like that that's
the words that's when they're
patronizing you
oh yeah that's what she does yeah I do I
think you misheard I love my wife - you
can't just laugh at your husband Stokes
you also have to say he's funny also yes
we need to hear it we did we are like no
no I thought my laughter was a sign that
I thought you otherwise you're just
kicking me between the legs all day long
ha ha ha you're so funny yes they say
men are dogs we are we need treats we
need good boy
we need all that stuff if I don't marry
a Leo I wouldn't have to do that but you
had the opposite of a Leo bro it's
actually because I love capricorns okay
thank you well you already what husband
are you what are you kept a Taurus oh
look hard uh burn that is true and
stubborn hmm what are you order you
Brandon Aquarius boring I forgot that me
existing yeah the court man what is it
Maya I'm chillin no it's just that the
people in my life that I tend to really
get along with happen to be Kepper got
it mama Isaac the Capricorn my sister is
alive everybody really great but not
best friends like we've been with Casey
I always forget his birthday nobody told
him the family trees are vertigo that's
not what her girls like this okay
submitted by coffee
I was late submitted my coffee is
basically water oh yeah throw with being
a [ __ ] ever dude there's so many
carcinogens in coffee that's why I drink
monster energy [ __ ] I'll get
what it's from a plant it's from a plant
organic what though dude what's even
organic it's a bit bananas not even
[ __ ] organic because all your not
again fabric that we wear laws can't
dude that's like my in my apartment
building is like there are chemicals
here to causing cancer wd-40 wd-40
oh is that that's the kid chemical that
they're referencing don't live in an
apartment building or whatever it is
dude you know as a placard on the wall
that's a California law I'm so glad they
did you know I was gonna lick this
[ __ ] wall I'm an idiot [ __ ] crazy
on a stage just reliability oh my god
residents are concerned after a DNA for
cash scheme pops up in poor
neighborhoods poor people checking
account why is that like a surprise
because they're always doing that
yeah like ancestry.com time is that you
have to pay to give your DNA to that
place
you do yeah poverty people they can't
pay to give us their DNA so we'll just
take it for free from them Oh we'll pay
them you it's probably the cash that
they give them is probably from the cash
that other people are paying to do at
23andme now we'll give it to you for
your DNA and they sell it to the
government what so much DNA though
they're creating a big why [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
so they can pin you for a crime you did
not do just like Minority Report see and
like Steve Avery and all the [ __ ] I
don't care I have guns
my dick is up in you for crime Oh blah
blah blah but you still you don't like
the nav collector but you still have the
fingerprint and iPhone se no I don't I'm
off the grid
[Laughter]
burne took my [ __ ] some prints on DNA
doesn't even mean anything though but no
like Oh Jay they had DNA everywhere and
they're like nah he's chill the glove
didn't fit bra I just I just spit a lot
I just spit a lot and I come a lot
Johnnie Cochran never tried to argue
about the cake good like what about the
DNA the LAPD is Rice's there's blood
here he took the shoes home the glove
doesn't fit it just always just change
the genius though he was genius played
with the jury's mind just he forget
about the facts emotion do cops white
politics is so strong with the motion
yes and that's what the dude what he did
with the photos to an OJ's house where
he replaced all black people yeah that
was smart as [ __ ] so boy with you go
Jays house his pictures were off with
like other famous white people all
people he Mike him and Dan Marino and
[ __ ] yes so they took the jury to his
house to like look around and stuff
before they did that they went in and
switched all the pictures with like
black people and like Kinte cloth and
all this stuff so people would be like
oh so the jury would be like oh he's a
real black man
the jurors a lot yeah they got people
who were black sympathetic but you know
the thing about OJ when you're black
you're just like man we finally beat the
system
sure don't you hate that it's OJ just
happened all the other [ __ ] shows like
it was like absolutely like a macro
perspective then like it was like come
on man we all know he did people who you
guys got that didn't deserve it so we
got a tape I will say that it was so
[ __ ] the way that they got him in
Vegas and they're like you were [ __ ]
kidnapping people
it's like bro this is like horseshit
you're just trying to charge them for
our Nicole murder absolutely but in
fairness if you get away with murder man
you got it get out of the way no you
know this book about his and Misha come
on looking like a true Christian thank
you exactly I agree
not agree more you got to lay the [ __ ]
low you're not getting away with it
twice yeah you got murder free bro yeah
enemy and what he robbed people right
now in Vegas he was just trying to get
his own memorabilia back from the
kidnapping is all you have to say is you
can't leave you don't have to physically
restrain anybody you just have really
you just have to block their ex all he
said was like nobody's going anywhere
till I get my [ __ ] basin and that's good
that's kidnapping
because you're not allowing people to
leave with their own cause you're
already anyhow to go yet oh yeah but you
say I'm a kidnap you guys come a kidnap
you guys you're not allowed to leave
right oh [ __ ] it's on video and you have
a gun I have an axe dare you 15 years i
kidnap you the closet school has a gun
oh stop don't leave the hammer out on
this story here there this is happening
in Kentucky in Louisville and they're
saying that there's this white van
that's showing up in the poorest
neighborhoods and they're offering for
$20 for your DNA but you have to be a
passport passport health customer and
what's that passport health is where you
go and get immunizations to travel or
you get like travel documents or yeah
get your shots clinics and stuff for
that what's like when you go to the
Philippines or when you go to so what do
they do
how do they collect the DNA can you spit
in this can you jack off in his cup go
straight to Jack you know there's
another way Jack Ava's give you like the
strongest stronger DNA what do women do
I don't know guys go just got a [ __ ] in
a cup if they're on their period just
just throw them the tampon
[Applause]
swapping the cheap this way it's way
easy oh I forgot about the cheap swab
cheek swab their cheeks like swabs what
if they kiss somebody though see mmm but
they get 20 bucks out of it and a lot of
these people are saying like oh man
after after I did it it just felt weird
Oh what what are they using it for like
what is the scam here no we there's a
scam going on going investigation
happening and that's what this whole
thing is about cuz this is one big-ass
mystery because as of right now we don't
know who these people are why they're
doing this they won't answer questions a
phone number that they provide doesn't
like the no one ever answers the white
vans got to be the creepiest vehicle
ever nothing good ever cooked no windows
no it's always it's kidnapping its DNA
cells it should be illegal to
manufacture wait it's just never like
the guy in the white man man he saved my
grandma nah man white vendor always
criminal what a white man salesmen are
they selling people like oh this guy's
definitely gonna do some crime mm
exactly
nobody's white man yeah unless they're a
plumber
no dude plumbers are [ __ ] at least
have some windows there and then it's
like okay you're not a bad guy have you
been in the house when the plumbers ever
feel shady dude yeah a plumber just came
to fix my toilet I was like something
shifty brother like I'm gonna stand over
you the whole time you're here because
you just had that look that's a yes
keep your eye on the book exactly no but
yeah so they don't know who these people
are why they are there collecting DNA
but it just you got DNA you got a
lecture recording your conversations
you got fingerprints from I'm glad I'm
not anyone important you do a lot of
that just came out to that Alexa
employees are listening to full
conversations people are having in their
home and yes you're not even saying a
lesson just exactly just recording it
and I read that if they're trained where
if there's like a disturbance to record
you like there's argument yelling like
crashing sound help it'll it'll help
it'll start recording good and they'll
use that in your
you know B so many recordings of me just
crying to myself all day just shouting
at the world and you guys make fun of me
about my mud I'm trying to get off the
grid and protect myself they're not
wrong what we start gonna make fun of
you about it well because why does it
have to be mud it could just be a tense
as I could block the 5 G's the 4G 3G the
big clay mud you could make a rock
structure like why's it gotta be mud
rocks is like - that bad for walls in a
room in the mud hut okay I can get
behind the dough because it's a big
cylindrical oh yeah and they they have
him by the mission in Santa Barbara - we
had to go tour it for the fourth grade
project someone's home and Pastor Joe
standing in front of a [ __ ] Rock Hut
like he's looking at a space shuttle -
rock stone masonry masonry is to it now
stone masonry is like that's like Middle
Ages I'm trying to go to primitive area
yeah totally
like just work with the earth you know
hmm
you like that Lost Tribe dude you see a
helicopter you like this because
underground I'm gonna have containers
like you know the the shipping
containers and I'm gonna create a silo
with that protect me from the five GS
and the people that are taking my DNA's
why do you think I'm creating the
stockpile of weapons and napkin yeah
napkins gotta have gotta have the napkin
what if you spill in your side I'm ready
for the apocalypse yo if if if the
apocalypse happened I'm gonna have the
cleanest mouth ever in the
post-apocalyptic world no [ __ ] stage
right here this is why I don't think the
apocalypse is coming let me say like so
so couple I mean three buildings went
down in New York City and we reacted
like the [ __ ] world just ended dude
so imagine the actual world ending god
knows what we'll do man it'll be [ __ ]
crazy 9/11 yeah yeah yeah my son wrote a
report about the Dark Phoenix I don't
know what that's cool I don't know what
this school is like reading his report
because I like emailed it to his teacher
because we forgot to print they were
like we just email it to you and he was
like man the Dark Phoenix man were to
say this from 9/11 I was like whoa what
is that yeah man because if the Dark
Phoenix there wouldn't be no 9/11 she
[ __ ] blew up New York dude that's
what I was I don't think you've an
understanding of the dark yes Jean Grey
like she got like consumed by a planet
she couldn't control her she's freaking
she like killed a buck billion people
then they just came back to earth and
she was like don't you're like if you
don't either don't understand 9/11 you
don't understand the Dark Phoenix like
one doesn't understand both he doesn't
he didn't read all the dark feet and he
just was like I gotta finish this report
two pages whatever dark phoenix beast of
a superhero Jojo
he's like Saddam Hussein would never let
this [ __ ] happen he's like Saddam
Hussein that guy was sick because I read
the first half of his biography like
about him coming up
[Music]